the moment we cry in a film is not when
things are sad but when they turn out to
be more beautiful than we expected them
to be and then devote dole oh the art of
the cinema
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
where I got sick of writing jokes so I
decided to do a video on sharknado where
the jokes write themselves spíritus Lee
sharknado 2 the second one sharknado 3
oh hell no
Wow just wow but in all seriousness with
April Fool's just insert number weeks
ago I thought it was the perfect time to
cover this ridiculous franchise and let
me assure you it is ridiculous
not since the room have I seen a movie
so bad take the world by storm get it
storm I can't tell what's worse this
week my jokes or the movie for those of
you who are too serious to appreciate a
terrible sci-fi movie first why are you
watching this channel and in particular
this video second get that stick out of
your butt bro third let me recap the
plot for you there are sharks and a
tornado the end shark NATO this isn't
rocket science in all seriousness though
the first sharknado is all about a
hurricane that sweeps up the Pacific
coast driving all the sharks in front of
it the hurricane hits Los Angeles a city
unprepared for so much rain and the
streets flood allowing sharks to swim
through the city the winds of the
hurricane kick up tornadoes which then
obviously suck up thousands of sharks
and proceed to launch them like deadly
toothy missiles throughout Hollywood
chaos and bad acting ensue they took my
grandfather hate sharks yet for as
stupid as it seemed at the time this
movie had everyone talking about it
including big companies the Insurance
Information Institute says that a shark
filled disaster would indeed be covered
in most homeowners insurance plans I'm
not making that up the first movie was
so popular there have been three made
and a fourth is on the way this summer
which got me thinking is any of this
possible if the director of the first
film is to be believed the answer is a
big No when asked about the realism of
the film director Anthony C Ferrante
said quote if we tried to go into how
realistic it is it wouldn't be fun if
you go into the science of it the whole
movie falls apart in the quote you know
that reminds me of something Verner
Hertzog once said academia is the death
of cinema it is the very opposite of
passion well screw you
I'm passionate about seeing whether
sharks can be launched by tornado force
winds through Central Los Angeles okay
go talk some more about insane penguins
is there such thing question of the day
is sharknado truly bad science I think
you and Anthony C Ferrante are gonna be
a little surprised first things first
animals falling from the sky is an
actual thing that happens in the world
no joke it's a rare meteorological
phenomenon known as raining animals and
it's exactly what it sounds like
animals falling like rain from the sky
raining frogs have been reported in
places like Australia Japan and Hungary
while worms have been reported in
Louisiana even spiders have been known
to rain in Brazil which is perhaps the
single most frightening sentence I've
ever written for this show spider rain
oh oh and here I thought Brazil's
political corruption was the scariest
thing going on down there right now
for as rare as these things are raining
fish is a much more common occurrence
with multiple reports in India Australia
the Philippines Sri Lanka and Ethiopia
with reports of fish rain happening as
recently as January of this year since
2000 there have been 10 locations around
the world where fish rain has happened
and in Honduras apparently it's happened
every year for over a century yeah
brings new meaning to the phrase flying
fish sometimes the animals are frozen or
encased in ice but other times yeah
they're alive startled to be sure but
still kicking or flopping in the case of
fish or wreaking terror through the
streets of Brazil lawns fighter rain no
I can expect what you're thinking how
how is this a thing I mean seriously
this sounds ridiculous like sharknado
levels of ridiculous but here's the
kicker scientists aren't really sure why
it happens pay to drop the ball their
science fish rain from the sky and
you're not in the least bit motivated to
solve that mystery what are you doing I
forget scientists someone call the
Boxcar Children they'll solve the
mystery the case of the trout shower or
something that said scientists do have a
couple of theories meteorological
theories the most popular one is that
you guessed it tornadoes pick up the
animals
carry them they're cold tornadic
waterspouts tornadoes that form over
land then move over to the surface of
the water these weather phenomenon are
powerful enough to pick up any number of
aquatic animals and move them great
distances overland interestingly enough
the writer of sharknado was actually
aware of this phenomena in an interview
with Gawker sharknado writer Thunder
Levin yes
thunder is his real name when you come
to think of it if you're the writer of
sharknado feels appropriate it'd almost
be funnier if the writer of sharknadoes
name was like Greg Smith
anyway Thunder said the following quote
there are numerous confirmed reports of
fish falling from the sky sometimes even
on a clear sunny day we just took that
to the logical extreme and quote it all
this really gives new meaning to the
phrase of raining cats and dogs that
said now that you're all curious there
have been no reported cases of actual
cats or dogs raining from the sky it's
okay cat Pat you're safe for now okay
so animals being picked up by extreme
weather has been recorded in the past
but I guess the next question is whether
it's possible for anything like that to
hit Los Angeles it's not like hurricanes
and tornadoes hit the west coast of the
United States all that often right well
while we mostly hear about hurricanes
hitting the east coast or the Gulf of
Mexico
they aren't entirely unheard of in
Southern California that said they are
very rare weather conditions and water
temperatures in the Pacific make
tropical storms and hurricanes hitting
the California coast and unlikely events
but again it's not impossible if you go
all the way back to 1858 you'll find a
full blown on weekend hurricane hitting
Los Angeles so who knows it could happen
again El Nino is a thing after all
meanwhile tornadoes aren't as uncommon
in California as you might expect though
tornadoes mostly happen west of the
Rocky Mountains there have been eight
that have touched down in Los Angeles
County between the years of 2000 and
2012 in the last 60 years there have
been a staggering 42 so at the very
least we know that it's possible for the
weather conditions presented in
sharknado to possibly exist but picking
up small fish or spiders is one thing
picking up a shark is a whole new
ballgame unsurprisingly they usually
weigh a lot more than fish blue sharks
are small ranging anywhere between 60 to
450 pounds mako sharks have an average
mass of 610 pounds tiger sharks have an
average weight of roughly nine
980 and great white sharks the ones
taking the starring role in sharknado
are some of the biggest weighing in
between 1500 and 2400 pounds that's a
lot of shark to scoop up and launch at a
chainsaw wielding ion ziering man ion
did you ever think that Beverly Hills
90210 would lead you to something this
cheesy this know piece is a little more
in tune with Who I am
okay less CGI equal amounts of cheese
classic nineties teen dramas aside does
a tornado have the ability to pick up
objects of that size well first we need
to quickly go over how the power of
tornadoes is categorized to do that
meteorologists use what's known as the
Fujita scale
I'll let the movie twister explain its
the Fujita scale it measures the
intensity of a tornado by how much it
eats it now that might sound like stupid
movie talk and the first time I heard
this quote I thought this was utter
movie garbage but it's actually correct
the scale is indeed based off of how
much the tornado quote-unquote eats or
better put how much damage the tornado
causes first developed by Theodore
Fujita of the University of Chicago in
1971 the Fujita scale has categories for
tornadoes of all shapes and sizes
everything from f0 small ones that reach
wind speeds of only 73 miles per hour to
f5 twister what do you have to say about
f5 tornadoes these monsters get up to
318 miles per hour they're the ones that
can pick houses clean off their
foundation and shred them in midair or
you know cause cows to fly now let's
take another look at the tornado
projects data from the Los Angeles area
most of the tornadoes happening in this
part of the United States either don't
have a rank or are the ranks 0 & 1 with
numbers that low you might think that
those aren't capable of doing much
damage but f1 tornadoes can blow cars
around that's some powerful wind but
just not powerful enough they don't
really have the strength to pick one up
off the ground if we keep looking though
five of the Los Angeles tornadoes have
been ranked 2 on the Fujita scale these
tornadoes are capable of reaching 157
mile-per-hour winds
enough to lift cars off the ground and
throw the
in 2010 the average new car weighed
around 4,000 pounds a tornado capable of
tossing something like that around would
easily be able to launch great white
sharks at Tara Reed which means that we
have several tornadoes that have hit LA
County that have also been strong enough
to lift even the heaviest of sharks so
theoretically a sharknado is plausible
but let's get really detailed there's
one final factor we haven't looked into
what the sharks be alive don't get me
wrong but tornado itself would freak me
out
a tornado launching dead animals at me
would be more than enough to get me to
pee my pants but a tornado launching
live sharks at me oh man screw
California I'm moving to Brazil oh wait
no spider rain Canada here I come so
much of the fun of the movie is that the
Sharks are alive as they get launched
jumping on our heroes and that unique we
didn't have an effects budget this is a
made-for-tv movie sort away
presumably all these sharks would
suffocate rights like all other fish
sharks breathe by using their gills they
swim with their mouths open which allows
water to pass over their gills allowing
their blood vessels to extract oxygen
from the water so in a tornado they'd be
out of luck right wrong it's logical to
assume that a tornado spinning over the
water picking up sharks is also going to
be strong enough to pick up water in
fact bill patzert a climatologist
interviewed about the movie has stated
that it stands to reason a shark could
indeed survive such a scenario there
would be enough water in the tornado to
keep it alive so there you have it based
on the research it is plausible that Los
Angeles could be hit with a tornado one
strong enough to lift sharks and the
water around them out of the ocean and
anyone that's been in Los Angeles during
the rainstorm knows those streets are
flooding in like five minutes
seriously all that said if we're being
entirely honest the premise behind
sharknado is simply absurd so many
unlikely things would have to happen in
order to make it a reality I suppose you
could say it'll happen when pigs fly to
which I respond know when sharks do but
hey that's just a theory a film theory
and cut
rain spider and get these [ __ ]
spiders out of my [ __ ] tornado
I was a terrible samuel l.jackson
impression swore I wouldn't do
impressions anymore